The fallout continues
from the incendiary comments
made yesterday
by rich-guy-taking-a-dare
way-too-far
-Donald Trump, when he...
-(laughter)
...seemed...
seemed to imply, uh,
encouraging violence
against Hillary Clinton.
Not... I mean, he didn't
flat-out say it,
but there was an implication.
CNN captured this GIF
of an audience member's
real-time reaction to Trump's
thinly-veiled
second amendment threat.
Uh, here it is.
Oh. Oh! Ho, ho, ho, ho.
-He sure...
-Ho, ho! -That's rich!
He sure crossed a line,
Mrs. Claus.
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
-Nice.
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Uh, with an unprecedented
possible death threat
against a presidential nominee
from a rival candidate,
the Secret Service leapt
into action,
leaving the White House lawn
exposed.
-Uh...
-(laughter)
...on social media by releasing
the following tweet.
(reading):
(laughter)
That is mildly
passive-aggressive.
Weirdly, they followed this up
with an Arthur meme captioned,
"When there's an assassination
threat on Bae."
(laughter, applause)
Comedians...
the tone of the previous
Twitter post is pretty annoyed.
What's another exasperated tweet
we might see from
the Secret Service? Jimmy Pardo.
Hey, @berniesanders,
your Uber has arrived.
-HARDWICK: All right. Yeah.
-(laughter)
-Please get in it. Please.
-Yeah, let's go.
-Moving on.
-Uh, Dave Krumholtz.
Hey, @realDonaldTrump,
there's only so much we can do,
so shut the (bleep) up.
-HARDWICK: All right. All right.
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
Uh, Doug Benson.
The Secret Service is tired of
tweets
about the Netflix show
Stranger Things.
-We're only on episode two.
-HARDWICK: All right, perfect.